i slowly began to hide all my unwanted
sorrow and pain
behind that toe that's a whiskey and a
straw full of cocaine
but somehow over time them glasses grew
taller and taller
and their lines the [ __ ] only
grew longer and longer and trust my
words and i stay on you my brother
i know like what i've seen from my
lifeless life became more and more like
how to control bad dreams as ashley rose
once stayed in the song
a little bit got more and more on how
true that is because i would do it
i would do it until my body couldn't
take anymore i literally stay awake for
days and days at a time
i take handfuls of sleeping pills just
an oversleep sweats and coat chills
it goes on and on but you get the point
all right solo solo where'd you grow up
where you from originally
west virginia ohio uh tri-state area
um but my family is from north carolina
and you know originally in west virginia
how was your childhood
i'm not so good
a lot of violence what kind of stuff was
going on
um watching my uncles beating fighting
people
um i've been missing people whacked as a
child
i've had to help dig a few holes as a
child
my uncle's taught me pretty much
everything i know both good and bad
i never had a father really it was drill
certain marine
um i watched my mom get beat all the
time
she's turned her anger and tore to me
i locked the room all the time beat on a
lot
how far did you go to school eighth
grade was the last grade i completed but
i got my ged in the penitentiary
i think the second or third time i win
second time i went
where were you in prison for oh it was
time
a lot of aggravated armed robbery
robbery burglary
but what it doesn't say is i targeted
certain type of child molesters and
rapists
um after my accident i couldn't work
my lady had my girl out sucking dick
just made him you know survive
i'm a piece of [ __ ] for pimping him but
it is what it is we had to survive um
i just started robbing the johns
after about the third time i saw the
love of my life come back with
eyes short broken ribs
all [ __ ] up but he beat the hell out
of her raped her and robbed her
i promised that she wouldn't want to
suck deep no more
so i started robbing them my first time
was with a bb gun
that i got from a walmart through the
hole out it literally looked real
i tapped on the window and it just
started from there
my eddie was from boston so she got that
boston accent
and she kept telling me get the bag in
the bag in the bag and i almost didn't
get the bag in the back
i reached back and i grabbed the bag
on the city bus this was our getaway
vehicle
we had a time just right back in the
woods where we had to get on the bus and
get the [ __ ] out of there
the bad had ten thousand dollars in it
brother
i opened the bag up about two minutes
into the bus ride matter of fact
when i opened it up i guess i don't know
what i was expecting i didn't expect
that
we rode the bus two more times bought a
van and took off
loving my life as a prostitute
me and her and my wife were together for
about four years
in the last couple of years i've lost my
mom
my my biological mom still alive i think
i don't know i we don't speak but my
adopted mom
she gone wife gone
kim gong [ __ ] dog even dying
i lost my job after 25 years
i had a [ __ ] named stacy and my troop
empty baby marijuana pin in the bottom
reverse state of wyoming charged me for
a dui
i lost my cdl's after 25 years spotless
cto's bringing over 2 500 bucks a week
after taxes
and now my hair
came here to find somebody because i
feel like i can't move all of my life
how my daughter was raped
she bled death out of her butt
me a lot of anger inside
i couldn't sleep at night
i want to kill the person who did it to
my child and i'm known for that [ __ ]
but yet i can't do it now and not gonna
bring her back
and they got me on this pr or [ __ ]
and if i catch any case at all it's a
minimum 15 years my kitchen in case i've
caught in the past whether i'm eating or
not it's 25 life
i don't want to go back to prison
um i came out here to do a christian
program
um nobody knew i was coming
but my hand the day i got here i stepped
off the bus somebody walked up to me and
told me
who they were and why they were there
and they were there to pick me up
and uh
i did go through the program and i've
been fighting with it
i've been fighting two chanel all the
way
um i was 107 to go to a certain place
here in the state of california
i went but then i got in the fight
um i didn't start it but
i wouldn't say i had to finish it either
but i put an end to it
um he was a good friend of mine i loved
him like a little brother
but he wanted me on some dope [ __ ] um
i did the program i i didn't get kicked
out he did
and there wasn't any bad
now i told the [ __ ] if they didn't let
him in said i wouldn't go back
that's how much i cared for this kid
and they wouldn't let him back in
so i told him no i left
i spent two thousand dollars and drove
five thousand miles to get my friend
carla out here
because she wanted to go to a program
this was all her idea
not mine not one i pushed on
oh her god me and my pastor finally got
her to the gates turn around took off
but uh my uh
my childhood was bad i always tried to
be a good father
but
somehow i didn't pull that off i guess
they think i chose harleys and hot rods
and
that semi my job i
you got to support him you know
i sold drugs for a long time i used to
be a hell of a cocaine dealer
and i never used it i didn't really do
job at all this week
until i lost my first wife
i slowly began i had all my unwanted
sorrow and pain
behind that tall glass of whiskey and
it's all full of cocaine
but somehow over time them glasses grew
taller and taller
and their lines the [ __ ] only
grew longer and longer and trust my
words and i stay on you my brother
and i like what i've seen from my
lifeless life became more and more like
an
out of control bad dream as ashley rose
once stated in the song
a little bit got more and more on how
true that is because i would do it
i would do it until my body couldn't
take any more i really stay awake for
days and days at a time
i take ample sleeping pills just an open
sleep sweats and coat chills
it goes on and on but you get the point
by myself all along that i was trying to
kill
and the pain and sorrow from a childhood
i always had a shame concurring dreams
since i've been like seven years old man
the same person there won the same gray
sweater
and then when i lost my daughter
that was my baby girl
i pretty much lost everything everybody
in the last couple years
two tears in a bucket [ __ ] it right
well i've come out here and it's like i
don't know man
carter a bunch of lies and second day
here that horde
took off
god was kicked out of new mexico at my
hideout because
not allowed to do drugs there and it's
the only thing that she was asked not to
do
i lived with a country music legend in a
ranch
i ain't trying to say no names but
i can't go back now she od there
four times
and that was the rule no drugs
i had to go out for property smoothly
um i was always doing the cocaine you
know i was really never into the meth
thing
um never really [ __ ] with it until
i don't know last two years maybe
in a very small amount
it makes me calm it's just the opposite
of what it does to everybody else i'm
adhd
i take five percocets saying the [ __ ]
tweaker alive can catch me
i'm 220 anyway so people always think
that
i'm doing speed when i'm not
um yeah my whole life has been number
violence hanging on my own my
uncles uh one for them i don't know my
mom was a piece of [ __ ]
um bad alcoholic
beat on the whole time
uh i never i never really put my hands
on my children
i backhanded one on one time
um right after i got
i had to do cancer and everything and
the surgeries
i got a bad left lung down i won't let
them remove it
no i've been in prison for aggravated
armed robbery
i like robbing people
but i don't rob good people not what i
call good people
um i don't like people to rape women
and if they're going to do it
not a six-year-old little girl i don't
think that's right
i was very active i was very violent and
in prison i was mad
pissed off my wife [ __ ] couldn't talk
to my kids
and then like why they were just walking
around nobody doing nothing to them
so i started getting their locker boxes
passing that [ __ ] out like robin hood
i'm a tattoo watcher so i do good in
prison
um i make real good money in prison
um
but my whole life's been about money
i've always had
beautiful house nice things
cadillac of every day of the week
harley's high-rise
and [ __ ] that was my thing
um
white trash john gotti
i got tattoos proven
cut the motorcycle wheel liquid bottle
but the whole trip losing my friend
carla
we were best friends chuck drove by
george w
semi you know we were all over the
united states
back again now we don't speak
i don't even know why because she's
screwing somebody else
i don't care
i came to l.a to find my friend
christina
maybe i loved her more than i thought
i miss her every [ __ ] day
um
i don't know i've been with two women
since
once for a few minutes
one a few times i don't want to be with
nobody
i've never had that problem i'm known as
a [ __ ]
i don't really want anything to do with
any of them
um yeah i miss christina the most
i i miss her hold real bad
more than not i've ever thought i knew
why lovers why i pushed her away
i knew i i loved your company you know
i'm just alone
i guess
bad rose i don't need it wrong because
i'm gonna be alone
i ain't gonna be with nobody else i make
sure that
i don't want to meet with nobody i miss
christine
tell me more about your childhood mother
always beating on me man
my stepfather dragged me out of bed
every morning by my ears probably while
i'm deaf right
um a lot a lot of
ass with a lot of physical
abuse no sexual [ __ ]
has that violence continued in your life
as an adult
i'd rather not really say on that one um
maybe i thought let me put it this way
maybe i thought i was a messenger
maybe i thought i was once seeing the
messages the bible said
but i've been pointed out from thomas
and then then
i'm not the messenger um
i've hurt people to the extreme
um i've made
their victims watch what i've done to
them
i pulled the speaker out of cars and
tied the [ __ ] up and put my
dirty socks under throat
and beat me i'm going to leave your jab
um then right there
a lot of goddamn gators everywhere um
it's about all my savior um
i don't feel bad for those things
because
when you do certain things your woman
and child
that's what you deserve
um there are some
things that are overlooked or i don't
have a problem overlooking
there's certain certain little things
that i don't think maybe some people
should be in prison for
i don't think a 21 year old kid is being
present for
screwing a 17 year old girl i don't
um but molesting a little child and
things like that
yeah my mother wasn't less than my wife
both my wife were
um it [ __ ] them up
but i see my uncles do a lot of things
my uncle work my uncle's work for the
mob
and the seal wasn't
i've seen a lot of [ __ ]
my family ran drugs we were a big horse
ranch
i dug the holes i got the dog
i stuffed the animals i put the garden
hoses down the throat
filled the cattle and horses and [ __ ]
and that's how we simply dope
do that to the animal plus you fill them
up with water they way more when they go
across the scale
and they lose a lot of weight
transferring
i did all that
um i know how to keep my mouth shut
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
and not to worry about what one has or
don't have
and worry about what's in front of him
my children my children
paid dearly for me in and out of prison
all the time
i've been like 16 different prisons
i'm a very violent person
i always go to maximum close security no
matter what
i don't have monkeys and [ __ ] like that
um
i don't know
a lot of violence man look it up
was the roughest time of your life
when i got out of the idaho i just lost
my job
every [ __ ] pain my semi all my [ __ ]
isn't new all the minutes so
so everything that these [ __ ]
went out stole my [ __ ]
i drove over 5000
i drove i went from over to mexico from
new mexico to ohio from west virginia to
ohio my
all over ohio all the way up to
minneapolis from indianapolis new album
new holland to denver from denver back
to silver city new mexico
then here um
i only had a couple grand left at the
bank
uh after being locked up and all this
and that
all right solo thank you so much for
coming in and telling me your story
thank you very much
you